john chapter 14 reading from verse one as
we begin the message the greatest crime
can possibly commit the world's greatest
crime john 14 reading from verse one
who's here for the first time may i see your
hands god bless you god bless you god bless you
say that from my heart let not your heart be
troubled you believe in god belief also in me
in my father's house are many mansions if it were
not so i would have told you i go to prepare a
place for you and if i go and prepare a place for
you i will come again and receive you unto myself
that where i am there you may be also and with
i go ye know and the way ye know thomas saith
unto him lord we know not wither thou goes and
how can we know the way jesus says unto him
i am the way the truth and the life no man cometh
unto the father but by me if he had known me
you should have known my father also and from
henceforth you know him and have seen him
philip says unto him lord show us the father
and it sufficeth us that's all we want jesus
show us the father and that's enough he said jesus
said unto him have i been so long time with you
and yet hast thou not known me philip he that
have seen me have seen the father and how says
thou then show us the father look at verse
nine again jesus said unto him have i been
so long time with you let me digress briefly what
does jesus mean by have i been with you so long
christ was coming to the end of his life
if you look at john chapter 13 14 15 16 17
almost all red letters because
this is christ's almost his final
speech to his disciples before in
verse 18 is in the garden of gethsemane
and so jesus is at the end of the three
and a half years of public ministry
and in three and a half years jesus
says you ought to have known me
intimately jesus almost sounds surprised have
i been with you so long three and a half years
yet today you hear christians say the lord
isn't done with me yet the lord is this the
lord is that that's the way i am and that
person has been walking with jesus 40 years
we have concluded it takes god a long time to turn
people around it does not take god long to change
us it takes god long to convince us we need to
be changed have i been so long time with you only
three and a half years and yet has thou not known
me philip question don't answer me do you know god
and why no god do we know god remember
the woman at the well john chapter four
she said to jesus i believe verse nine how is
it that thou being a jew ask his drink of me
which i'm a woman of samaria for the jews have
no dealings with the samaritans then jesus said
if thou knewest the gift of god if you knew who
i was your question would have been different
you wouldn't ask me why are we interacting
you would have asked me for living water
the problem many of us have
is we simply do not know god
now we know the seventh-day adventist church
we know the baptist church the lutheran church
but we don't know god because if we knew
god some things we do now we would never do
some things we say we would never say and
that's the message jesus told that woman
if you knew the gift of god you would
never ask me what you just asked me
your question would be different do you and
i know god if we knew god we would not treat
people the way we treat them if we knew god
the way we should we would not take this casual
lackadaisical approach to church attendance if
we knew god we would have a serious and urgent
a sense of emergency regarding the study of
god's word if we knew god we would care for
this body if we knew god we would be concerned the
influence we have on the unbeliever if we knew god
but god wants to be known and so jesus
says have i been so long time with you
and yet has thou not known me philip he
that have seen me have seen the father
jesus is telling philip that one of his duties
his responsibilities his functions his roles his
purposes on this earth was to reflect the father
so so perfectly that if you see jesus you see god
with respect to character i'm suggesting
i'm not suggesting jesus has the same
nose the father has i no one has seen
the father no one has seen the father
but what the bible stresses is the character the
mind the character of jesus is the character of
the father in every detail the mind of jesus is
the mind of the father now i am stressing now that
jesus came to reveal the father so that anyone
who looked at jesus honestly would know exactly
what the father was like there is no need to see
the father when you see jesus now let me take
one step further there is no need to see jesus
in the flesh when you see one of his children
let me say it again differently
when people see us they should have no need
to say show us jesus and it suffice for us
because by looking at us they
should be looking at jesus
are you understanding me
and i'm not watering down what i just said by
looking at us they should be looking at jesus
there are some people who believe that god
requires of us that we come close to christ
but we can't ever be just like christ where
we can't ever be god but we can be christ-like
we can be godly and god-like higher than
the highest human thoughts can reach
is god's ideal for his children godliness
god likeness is the goal to be reached
godliness god likeness christ likeness is
the goal and i've told you a few nights ago
god does not lower his standards he provides
power to lift us up to reach his standards
in the first peter chapter 1 verses 80 19
for as much as you know that he were not
redeemed with corruptable things as silver and
gold received by tradition from your fathers
but with the blood of the precious blood of
christ as a lamb without blemish without spot
notice the description without blemish without
spot that's the description for christ listen to
the description for the church ephesians 5 25-27
husbands love your wives even if christ also loved
the church and gave himself for it that he might
sanctify and cleanse it with the washing of water
by the word that he might present it to himself
a glorious church not having spot or wrinkle
or any such thing but that it should be holy and
without blemish the same description for jesus is
a description for his people we cannot reflect a
partial image of jesus christ it confuses people
i never said we can be god we cannot be god
ah but we're called by god to be godly we're
called by christ to be christ-like we're called
by the spirit to be spiritual in human flesh
and the world needs to see a
people in whom is reflected
the character of jesus christ
i remember i read a story some
time ago whether it's true or not i don't
know but it makes a valuable point this
man was in a village somewhere little
town and someone came to see him
and the story goes that after talk to the man
can be given bible study and uh
the bible study person the christian
given the study was talking about jesus
and the old man white beard and sitting
in his rocking chair he said i know jesus
so the the christian said what do you
mean you know jesus you don't go to church
you don't pray you don't how do you know
jesus the man he lives down the street
so the person was naturally baffled befuddled
bamboozled and bewildered what do you mean
jesus lives down the street he said yes i know
the man you're talking about if the man you're
talking about is the man you're talking
about i know him he lives down the street
well naturally the the the person's curiosity
was raised to high heaven bubbling over
he said show me this jesus the old man got up
picked up his stick and he and this person went
down the street knocked on the door and out came
an old man and the other old man said that's jesus
the lady said how come well everything
you told me in this book that's him
he is kind he's forgiving he's unselfish
he takes the bread out of his mouth
gives it to me if this is jesus that's him
now he should also have said jesus is you
as funny as that may sound
we have to be reflectors
of the image and the glory of jesus christ
by glory i mean the character of jesus christ
so that people say i know jesus jesus
goes to medical school at loma linda
jesus does public health at loma linda
jesus lives in the city of loma linda
now when we fail to give that message
at what risk do we put the world
let's go to genesis chapter 12. reading
from verse 10 the world's greatest crime
genesis 12 reading from verse 10.
for public reading if you're here for the
first time i use the king james version
the bible says and there was a famine in
the land and abraham went down to egypt to
sojourn there for the famine was grievous in
the land and it came to pass when he was come
near to enter into egypt that he said unto
syria his wife behold now i know thou art
a fair woman to look upon therefore it shall
come to pass when the egyptians shall see thee
that they shall say this is his wife and they
will kill me but they will save thee alive
say i pray thee thou art my sister that it
may be well with me for thy sake and my soul
shall live because of thee now abraham tells
sarah lie or be creative in your explanation
and it came to pass that when abraham
was coming to egypt the egyptians beheld
a woman that she was very fair the
princess also of pharaoh saw her and
commanded her before pharaoh and the
woman was taken into pharaoh's house
and he entreated abraham well or abram well for
her sake and he had sheep and oxen and men served
and he asses and men servants and maidservants
and shias and camels and verse 17 the bible says
the lord plagued pharaoh and his house with
great plagues because of syria abraham's wife
now why did god plague pharaoh's house god
didn't kill him but he got his attention
but the plague was a precursor to
destruction if he had not let syria go
when pharaohs realized what was happening in
his household the bible says in verse 18 then
pharaoh called abram and said
what is this thou has done to me
you are hurting me you have put me at
risk you're putting my life on the line
the life of my people abraham
believer in the living god
abraham hebrew abraham father of the specially
called nation what is it thou has done to me
when we reflect jesus in a dim
hazy way the world says to us
seventh-day adventists what
is it that you're doing to us
we have no other source of information
about who jesus christ is and we look to
you to show us by the life you live what
jesus is all about and we are confused
because what we hear you say
differs vastly from what you do
what is this the thou has done to me
and abraham how do you explain sin you can't
well you can say it's a sinful nature but that
doesn't wash or fly because no devil anywhere
can make anyone sin so the chapter records no
response from abraham perhaps with a sheepish look
pharaoh put him out can you imagine the disgrace
god's people put out because of deception now
it's one thing to be evicted because you've
lift up jesus christ peter was imprisoned
paul was told yes we suffer for the cause
of christ but peter said let us not suffer
as a thief or anyone else who has sinned
we should not suffer because we sin we should
suffer because we're faithful to jesus christ
and pharaoh threw this man out
because he deceived an unbeliever
his witness was potentially lethal
genesis chapter 20 oh brother abraham again this
time it's a philistine king called abimelech
the story begins in verse one we'll just go right
down to verse six where god says yeah i know thou
didst this in the integrity of thy heart god
is saying look i know you took the man's wife
without knowing the full story now verse 7 says
now therefore restore the man his wife for he's a
prophet and he shall pray for thee and thou shalt
live and if thou restore her not nor thou that
thou shalt surely die thou and all that are dying
abimelech i will wipe out your entire country
well in verse 8 if god told you that in
a dream you wouldn't sleep much longer
the bible says then abimelech rose early
in the morning and called all his servants
and told all these things in their ears
and the men were so afraid grown men
verse 9 genesis 20 then abimelech called
abraham i would have loved to see abraham's face
then abimelech called abraham said
unto him what hast thou done unto us
but he goes further than pharaoh he says and what
have i offended thee that thou has brought on me
and on my kingdom a great sin and here's
the one that really must have heard abraham
thou hast done deeds unto
me that ought not to be done
there are some things believers we should not do
to the world and one of them is mislead the world
even the world knows there's
some things we shouldn't do
this unbeliever this idol worshiper this
philistine who worshipped the fish god
dagon looking into the eyes of a
man described as a friend of god
the father was specially called people and
telling him you should not have done this
it is embarrassing when the
world rebukes the church
what have i offended thee abraham what did i
do that thou has brought on me on my kingdom
a great sin thou hast done deeds unto me
that ought not to be done and bim like not
yet satisfied he must have been suffering from
just intense consternation in verse 11 he says
what saw us thou what did you see about me and
my people that thou has done this thing what
was there in me and my people that led you
to be so traitorous and treacherous now what
does a child of god say when the world issues
such a stinging rebuke and the world is right
would you like your child to
confront you in the judgment
why didn't you restrain my urges why did you give
me everything i wanted what have you done to me
why did you allow me to spend half of my life
in front of a television set and video games and
whatever else why did you do that i developed
a mind with no appreciation for that which is
spiritual now i couldn't care less about god
mother father what is it the vow has done to me
when i was a little boy and i wouldn't listen
to my mother she always told me this story
hope she doesn't see this tape
she tells the story of a man who was in
prison a life of crime he's imprisoned
for life not for life or he's to be
executed and he sent for his mother
and the mother came long tears flowing down her
wrinkled face and he said mother come close to the
bars i need to tell you a secret and the mother
came close to the bars of the cell where he was
and the son said mother come closer
put your ear right through the bars
the mother put her ear right through
the two bars and he bit off her ear
and he said as he spat it out
if you had made me listen to you
i would not have been here
you should have insisted that i listen
to your instructions but you allowed me
to do whatever i want that's why i am here
and he had every reason to say to his
mother what is it that thou has done to me
young men with girlfriends what is it
that you're doing to your girlfriends
young ladies with boyfriends
what is it that you're doing to that
man who desires to be a preacher
teachers with authority over students
you're greeting the paper based on how
you feel it's not a 10 out of 10 eight out of
nine it's what are you doing to your students
preachers
what are you doing to your congregations
do you have the courage the spiritual spine to
stand up and preach the truth for the truth alone
sanctifies or do congregations have a right
to say what is it that thou has done to me
we have in our power to hurt people very badly not
by the weapons that we ordinarily associate with
violence but by our influence by the hypocrisy of
our lives we say one thing we do something else
now abraham had a son called isaac
13 minutes to eight genesis 26
you know parents if you're considering having
children you want to watch how you behave yourself
because your children will not only inherit the
color of your hair they'll inherit your attitudes
so it pays to be upright and nice if only
for the sake of the offspring you can
offspring you're considering
having here is abraham's son
he is facing a famine genesis 26 verse 1 the bible
says and there was a famine in the land beside the
first famine that was in the days of abraham and
isaac went into bim like king of the philistines
antagira abraham had his famine years later jacob
would have his famine there are three famines in
genesis one for each of the three patriarchs
now isaac the lord appeared to him verse two
genesis 26 and said go not down into egypt dwell
in the land which i shall tell you of sojourn in
this land for i will be with thee and will bless
thee for unto thee and unto thy seed i will give
all these countries and i will perform the oath
which i swear unto abraham thy father and i will
make thy seed to multiply of the stars of heaven
and i will give unto thy seed all these countries
and in thy sea shall all the nations of the
earth be blessed because abraham obeyed my voice
and kept my charge my commandments my statutes and
my laws and verse 6 says and isaac dwelt in girard
now verse 7 and the men of the place
asked him of his wife and he said
what she's my sister like
father like son like like mother
like mother yes let's be fair here
and the men of the place asked him of
his wife and he said she is my sister
for he feared to say she is my wife les said he
the men of the place should kill me for rebecca
because she was fair to look upon same situation
with his father in genesis 12 and genesis 20.
verse 8 and came to pass when he had been
there a long time that behold abimelech king
of the philistines looked out at the window
and saw and behold isaac was sporting with
rebecca his wife they were playing around he was
caressing her that was his right come on say amen
and abimelech called isaac and said
behold of assurity she is thy wife
and how set us down she is my sister
and isaac said unto him because i said
lest i die for her he was protecting
his skin as his father was
and the biblic said what is this
thou has done unto us unto me same question
three times twice in the life of abraham once
in the life of isaac the unbeliever is put in
mortal danger by the treachery of the believer
one of the people might likely have lane
with thy wife and thou should have brought
guiltiness upon us abimelech said some
man might have gone to bed with your wife
and that would have bring the wrath of
your god on us isn't your plate straight
brethren we ought to play
it straight or don't play it
it's better to leave god
alone i mean severely alone
than to have a half-hearted
half-stepping relationship with him
we're told in second peter
chapter 2 i believe it's verse 20
it were better for them not to
have known the way of righteousness
of verse 21 then after they have known it to
turn from the holy commandment delivered unto
them second peter 2 21 it is better not to know
than to know and go against what you and i know
and so abimelech in genesis 12 and abraham
pharaoh in genesis 12 deceived by abraham
abimelech genesis 20 deceived by abraham
abimelech genesis 26 deceived by isaac
it is a crime against the world when
god's people misrepresent his character
we're talking about the world's greatest
crime because god cannot come down
to represent himself he needs us as he
needed jesus when jesus left jesus and
the spirit to represent him and through us
we reflect the character of jesus christ
to save their skins they compromised there is
another reason why we compromise when we try
to establish ourselves as famous and well-known
even if it means changing the way god told us
to do things genesis 11 reading from verse one
the bible says and the whole world was of one
language of one speech and it came to pass as they
journeyed from the east that they found a plane in
the land of china and they dwelt there and they
said one to another go to let us make brick and
burn them thoroughly and they had breakfast straw
and slime had there for martyr and they said go
to let us build us a city and a tower whose top
may reach up to heaven and let us make us a name
lest we be scattered abroad
upon the face of the whole earth
the inhabitants of the tower of babel they their
intention was to make a name for themselves
separate from the name god would have
them carry let us make us a name and
their name was based not on character but on the
construction of two buildings a city and a tower
don't answer me but here
this question how many of us
are trying to build a name based on non-spiritual
foundations by a degree or a purchase
or a relocation to a more high-priced neighborhood
they were seeking to build a name on the basis
of a city and a tower not the basis of the quality
of the character and today christians fall into
the same trap because they're influenced by
the world that's how the world builds a name
but do you know building your
name is not your business
it's six minutes to eight give me five more
minutes five after eight can you do that for
me please thank you let's go to genesis chapter
12 the very next chapter we saw in the life
of abraham and isaac they misrepresented god
to save their own skin physically many of us
misrepresented god because we come into conflict
with how god desires us to develop a name genesis
12 god's message abraham reading from verse one
now the lord had said unto abram get thee out
of thy country and from thy kindred and from thy
father's house unto a land that i will show thee
and i will make of thee a great nation and i
will bless thee and do what make thy name great
now making my name pray is god's business
making god's name great is my business
by the life i live by the reflection of
the character of jesus in me i give god
a name and god is so delighted and excited he
gives me a name i will honor them that honor me
but we reverse it and we set out
to make our own names when a man
goes contrary to god's recommendations he
comes into conflict and he clashes with god
i don't care if you pursue
it at a christian school
and so we are here seeking a name
many young people they'd love to go to christian
school but the parents say no you've got to go to
harvard because the the the the diploma has a name
and that name is worth 20 000 more dollars a month
and puts your soul in jeopardy
i was talking to a young man a
few years ago at a youth retreat
crying a young lady she said
pastor in order to talk to you
what's the problem i have one foot in the world
one foot in the church and i'm about to close
i said explain she said when i was in high school
my parents and i said are they adventists
yes they pushed me to attend secular schools
because secular schools have higher
reputations than adventist schools
i wanted to go to an adventist school and
be in that environment imperfect as it is
all right have one courageous person over here
imperfect as our schools are i prefer to
have my children in one of our schools
and she said they insisted i go to school that
has a name she said i went i obeyed my parents
she said from the time i set foot in that school
every belief of mine which i barely understood was
challenged and my faith began to crumble and now
with tears on her eyes running down her cheeks she
said i have one foot in the church and one foot
in the world anyone of you who goes to the gym to
lift which you know one foot is always stronger
than the other her strong foot was in the world
and we sacrifice our children because some parents
they get their name by what their children do
now you regret you invited me i
know it i can see it it's okay
your mistake was to invite me the first place
there are parents who get their name based on the
accomplishments of the children and so thinking
of themselves they push and drive their children
right out of the church and cannot understand
why the child has no interest in spiritual things
because they're seeking a name god's work is
to give us a name our job is to give him a name
when we confuse the two job responsibilities
god loses and we stand in danger of being lost
the world's greatest crime is
to reflect christ in such a
jaundiced way that those looking on
are misled confused and ultimately fall
god will not allow that to pass unpunished
the greatest work on the face of the earth is
preaching i'm not saying that because i'm here
it really is after the work of saving people
the greatest work is talking about what jesus
does not only preachers do that doctors do it
the greatest crime is to lead someone to hell
ella white writes if you're not an adventist
ellen white is one of our best writers our
best writer actually get her books your life will
change i love to talk about her she said in the
judgment many parents will be shocked to learn
that what their children became is their fault
now i take no pleasure in telling you
that particularly since i have no children
but my status as a non-father
does not change what the word says
we must not mislead those who look at us and
don't waste time telling people look to jesus
the bible says in first john
4 verse 20 i believe it is
he that loveth not his brother whom he have
seen how can he love god whom he has not seen
you can tell people look to jesus all you
like they cannot see jesus they can see you
and they can see me here's my question at 8
o'clock i have five minutes left don't answer
me think when people look at us and how we behave
in the classroom in the cafeteria ordering food at
the restaurant how we dress the music we listen to
how we spend our money what we study what we watch
our language are they getting
the real story about jesus
when they see our children do they say i would
like my children to be just like those children
do our children come home and say i want to be
like those people out there or do the people
out there go home and tell their parents i want
to be like that 7th adventist 12 year old boy
do children in the world go home and tell
their parents mommy i'm tired dressing this
way i want to dress like my friend who goes
to the adventist church or is it the reverse
the good news is if we have been
misrepresenting god it can stop tonight
you can stop tonight
you see you can fool me and most
people do fool me i'm easily fooled
you can't fool god and you'll fool
yourself more convincingly than you fool me
we cannot fool god i can fool you i can't fool god
because my life is an open book to god and so is
yours but i'm saying to you god holds no grudges
god forgives almost reflexively
instinctively automatically just forgives
and if we are convicted in our
hearts tonight by this message
we have misrepresented god he will forgive
us the moment we say lord i'm sorry
ask him to lay on our hearts a conviction to
represent him right on the job at home at play
wherever we are in our children whatever we do
we want to show the world this is jesus that
the world has no reason to say the seventh-day
adventists what is this that thou has done to me
and i say tonight lord if i have misrepresented
you forgive me forgive me yes preachers
misrepresent if i have done it and i know i have i
apologize to god because i don't want to continue
anyone who will say father i know in the privacy
of my heart as your holy spirit ripples the pool
of my decency i have misrepresented you if you
can say that with the coverage that comes from
the spirit i want you to stand up and
you're saying i want to do it no more
i don't want to continue exerting an influence
that may take people downward i don't want
it on my conscience that someone is in some
rehabilitation program because of my influence
i don't want it on my conscience some
young girl at 19 has three children
because of my influence i want to know some young
man is in school because of my influence some
families in church because of my influence
a man is off drugs because of my influence
and because i have represented christ the right
every head bowed every eye closed loving father
in heaven we come to you in the name of jesus we
plead we beg we appeal we urge we importune you
forgive us for the crime of misrepresenting
you dear god and perhaps leading people on a
downward slope to destruction father if we
have done this we ask in the name of jesus
to do all you can to undo the damage we have done
to friends to family to children to those whom
we don't know undo the damage they got and save
those whom we have hurt by our hypocritical lives
oh father in heaven open our eyes to understand
that it is through us that you show the world
the character of your son forgive us their father
not only give us forgiveness but give us power to
live above that which we have been doing that
we receive from you tonight forgiveness and
overcoming power hear us put your spirit in
our hearts bring us back tomorrow night we pray
and i thank you in jesus name let
all god's people say with me amen